so welcome to this free webinar
on sequence to structure this is part of
an ongoing omics logic genomic program
which we had started
on march 12 2021 we will focus
on how to connect the various elements
of analysis
of genomic data to insights that are
actionable in context
of a particular project my name is
beepsha biswas and i'm the omix logic
community manager working closely
with participants who join us from
around the globe
from different academic and research
backgrounds
this program is part of an omits logic
bioinformatics training program for
infectious diseases that started in
january 2021
and will continue until july 2021.
the first part of this program was on
infectious disease
and focused on the use of bioinformatics
and
big data for infectious disease research
diagnostics as well as drug
and vaccine development
this webinar is part of this second
session which is omics logic genomics
in the second phase of the training
program participants are learning about
concepts and
analytical tools used to study genomic
variation in infectious diseases
each week participants are meeting
online to discuss
various aspects of ngs data processing
genomic data analysis and interpretation
in the next phase of this training
program
we will focus on rna-seq analysis
this training will include methods of
machine learning for bulk and single
cell gene expression studies
special focus on examples for infectious
disease research
such as malaria covid19 disease
prognosis
immunology and biomarkers so this
program starts on april 16th
now that i've given you a background of
this webinar that we are having today
let me talk a little more about what
omics logic program is for
those who have joined us for the first
time omixlogic is an international
program which is running in five
different regions with over 10 000 users
across the globe
due to this fast growth the company is
working with the local and regional
coordinators who are helping refine
local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers
around the world the omits logic
programs
follow a project-based learning approach
which we are going to be
talking more about today in later part
of this webinar
using research grade tools to analyze
data from
top peer review journals this omits
logic training has been completed by
over 10
000 participants from 162 countries in
over 300 workshops
for six different specialization tracks
which
include oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training
on omics data analysis
in the upcoming program you will have
the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
specialized in the application of data
science to biological data sets
let me introduce you to the program
mentors
who many of you may have already
interacted with we have dr harpreet kaur
as our certified omix logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician who guides these
hands-on sessions and
assists participants with projects and
analysis
during each of these omics logic
training programs her area of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
with over 10 years of experience working
with industry and academia
elia brodsky is the ceo and co-founder
of
pine biotech in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners who are
applying multi-omics integration
bioinformatics
to a variety of biotechnology and
clinical applications
i will now like to invite elia to talk
more about sequence to structure
which is a topic for today's webinar
over to you elia thank you
thank you very much pizza and welcome
everybody to this webinar so
before we start let me introduce myself
uh
as beeps mentioned my name is ilya
bronski i'm the co-founder and ceo of
i'm
and our vision here pine biotech is to
enhance human health and well-being by
enabling
biological research and discovery with
relevant data
solutions and expert support and so one
of the questions that i want to talk
about today is how can bioinformatics
actually
assist in this vision so to clarify
the mission that we have is to simplify
bioinformatics and advance various
research projects through our modular
and intuitive multi-omics analysis
platform
that is powered by both human experience
and artificial intelligence
and what we do is we offer training
research support and big data analytical
tools
that are designed for research and
biomedical discovery
so today i want to talk to you about
how we will be able to leverage genomic
data to arrive at
meaningful and actionable results for
infectious disease
and so this is important because i want
to focus on this
aspect of actionable so how can we
make research in infectious diseases
using genomics
into translational research that could
be applied
so the basic question is given the
availability of genomic data
the widespread data collection and
analysis efforts around the world
what specific issues are hindering or
preventing the translation of this
research
interaction and so to talk about it i
want to
focus on the specific elements of
bioinformatics that can help us
align data using a variety of references
that we have to
be purposeful about selecting
how we question the data and what
specific
aspects of the relationships we focus on
and then how we can translate that
insight on the
sequence level to the structure and how
we can
model and analyze the interaction
between different proteins
to improve our models
and so here are some specific things
that we can
discuss in the context of basic to
translational research so in the
beginning
we typically focus on hypothesis
generating research questions and so
a lot of these questions are really to
find patterns
explore their consistency and
significance and start focusing in
on a particular element of that
variation
then we go to hypothesis testing where
this hypothesis that we've generated
from maybe a small collection of data
we want to test whether it is
translationable
for the whole population and here we
have to define what is that population
that we are interested
in and then finally we want to think
about
what are the actionable insights that we
can
extract from this knowledge and so if
you kind of think about it
from getting an idea to specifically
generating knowledge that kind of helps
put that idea
into the proper context that is
essentially
what is needed for action or for the
implementation of that knowledge
that probably has a lot to do with
communicating
and convincing other people of how this
particular insight is relevant
to an intervention maybe increased
data collection or maybe a long-term
strategy that can
involve multiple people that have to
work together
and so the basic question again remains
how can we translate this
information from bioinformatics analysis
of genomic data
to a translational impact and so
if you look on the
american society of molecular data
you can find the definition for
translational bioinformatics which is
the development of
storage analytic and interpretive
methods to optimize
the transformation of increasingly
volume
voluminous biomedical data and genomic
data into
proactive predictive preventive
and participatory health and so
what defines bioinformatics in the era
that we are
in is that we are seeing an increasingly
huge volume of complex data that has a
lot of variation as we will see in
today's session
into clinically useful knowledge that
requires the convergence of molecular
bioinformatics
biostatistics statistical genetics and
clinical informatics
that are translated into computational
easy to use methods
that can be used to establish a better
or a more practical and accelerated path
from discovery
to improved care and so along the way
it's important that the discoveries
become
practically useful so to achieve this
goal
we are essentially looking at the
advancement
of translational genomics that are
going to turn this large data or
big data into some practical questions
that
could be answered and can have a major
impact
and so before we kind of go on
i want to highlight some of these
elements of what translation might look
like
and so one of those is identifying
flawed science so a lot of times
scientific publications include
a lot of different data sets and and
it's often
easy for us to see it from outside but
it's difficult when you're a part of a
research project to understand the
biases
that drive the research question and so
these biases could be many
and i want to ask you here i'm imagining
that many of you are involved in some
kind of research
so what are some of the biases that
you might imagine that drive
flawed science so what are maybe some of
the
reasons why we have flawed science what
do you think
okay so to answer the question you can
uh write your answers in the chat so
hopefully we can have a discussion about
each one of these points just really
briefly so
what do you think might be uh some of
the you know things that
could drive flawed science okay so aina
is saying
poor statistical sampling numbers okay
so
incorrect data right selecting bad data
poor data okay great thank you sanjeev
what what other things okay gap between
understanding the data and
interpretation
excellent technical errors batch effects
that includes technical errors batch
effects
okay high error rates incorrect data
maybe data that was
incorrectly collected excellent so good
question so
essentially okay so
now we'll get to methods here in a
section so wrong assumptions
okay excellent i o thank you so we can
identify
flawed science by revisiting
the research projects that have been
published
looking for gaps and limitations that
led to incorrect interpretation right
and so that is a big part of translating
our efforts into something practical
identifying that flawed science
essentially
leads to new questions about how that
particular
assumption could be addressed adjusted
improved
and ultimately lead to novel insights
now the other part of it is how can we
improve our estimates and so somebody
already
mentioned here that we have proper
methods to analyze data right so
we have typically we operate by having
estimates so we estimate the rate of
mutations we estimate
the level of expression we estimate the
uh frequency of occurrence those
estimates
are based on on our understanding of the
problem and so
to improve those estimates when we come
at a problem
we need to collect more data that will
lead to better estimates right so
uh again if we kind of think about it
together
what do you think are some examples
where
better data or better contextualized
data
can improve our estimates
okay so if anyone wants to again pitch
in just
put your answers in the chat box so
how can how can better data or better
contextualized data
improve estimates
okay so swathi is answering data
cleansing and class labeling can be done
minimize deviation um
okay so so let's imagine
for example the current situation with
the pandemic with the pandemic
we have millions of samples being
collected from around the world
from the covet 19 pathogen right and so
the question is is that sampling
consistent
throughout all of the regions can we
improve our estimates of emergence
of novel mutations and variants of
concern
based on better data that is collected
in a more uh precise way from around the
world right so for example if i have
you know over sampling in the us and
under sampling in argentina
could we improve the balance and so get
a better picture
of how this virus continues to evolve
right
so those are some of the questions that
we could again
improve uh by looking at the quality of
sampling
thank you leanna taking advantage of
larger data right so sometimes
we only focus on a small portion of data
and that leads us to
ignore the information that we have from
the rest of the data that we have
available
sometimes it's the opposite way we want
to take a look at everything but we are
ignoring the quality of the data
and so instead of looking at the overall
trends we're
biased by this incorrect data
okay so sanjeev is mentioning using the
same platform for analysis
maybe this means that we're only looking
at one particular type of methodology or
maybe we're looking at one particular
type of sequencing for example or data
collection methods
all right so thank you for your insights
that's
uh that's really good to hear so now
let's talk about how
we can infer new insights about
mechanism of disease so again
we have typically uh this
textbook knowledge of actual disease
kind of mechanisms and uh patterns
of progression and so a lot of times
that is because
the knowledge accumulated over years
gets
internalized and translated into these
static models right and so we say that
typically a virus enters the cells
starts replicating
inside that replication there's a
certain machinery
that is hijacked and eventually we have
this progeny of
a novel virus but in reality this
is a highly dynamic process and so
instead of basing our understanding on
just a static model we are moving
towards
dynamic modeling of various aspects of
mechanisms of disease and disease
progression
that have to be generated through data
and so a lot of that goes back to the
data that is collected
that is being analyzed that is being
converted into a dynamic model that
could be refined from patient to patient
from country to country
from infection to infection and so
some of these elements here on the
screen i think should give us an idea
of how challenging translational
bioinformatics really is
and what kinds of efforts are needed to
make specific research questions
answered in an
actionable way and so that is one of the
reasons
why we are thinking of how we can
develop a roadmap for translational
bioinformatics that includes
a process of helping researchers
scientists and students find relevant
data sets that are available
for public use how to properly explore
and visualize to get a sense of what
kinds of variation
are standing out and are critical and
interesting for
further research we prioritize
a development of research methods that
are easy to use and compare
and also explain the basis of these
research methods so that they are used
with an understanding and ultimately we
are looking to connect
the data with the insights and
understanding
through this process of translational
research and so one of the programs that
omixlogic
developed for infectious diseases is
this program called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and so just to give you an
idea of what kinds of topics were
covered so far in this program already
this program is really intended to
help guide the understanding of
pathogens and disease that they cause
by looking at zoonotic transmission
viral evolution
and replication as well as bacterial and
infections we also talked a lot about
how to collect
genomic transcriptomic and metagenomic
data
that help us understand and
contextualize disease
and apply that to the questions arising
about
the emergence and the intervention of
these disease
including vaccine design antiviral drug
design and
antibiotic resistance as well as
epidemiological trends
and drug resistance and so we also
do this using projects where we take a
look at recent epidemics like ebola
zika and dengue we look at coronaviruses
that are being talked about so much now
mycobacterium tuberculosis and leprosy
as well as
malaria and so as a result of this
program
we are really trying to address this
important aspect of infectious diseases
that have
a prevalence around the world and are
causing about 11 million deaths per year
where the impact primarily is focused on
mortality
but very specific interventions that are
driven
by people that are in the position of
some of you here that are present and us
that are interacting with researchers at
various academic centers can really make
an impact
and one of the primary ways that we
could address this growing challenge of
infectious diseases
is really change the way we think about
the impact to only be preventative
or interve intervention in terms of
treating that disease right because
there is such a disconnect between the
research
and the actual practical action that
could be taken
as a result as a result of those
insights
and one of those examples is just simply
surveillance and i think that we can see
how that is being done today so in the
context of covet 19
we saw that no surveillance as opposed
to
surveillance with a purpose to detect
identify and explore data sets that are
being collected in an
active way can lead to a significant
reduction
in the number of cases in the number of
deaths from those infections and so you
can see here
the number of cases that increases as a
result of no surveillance and
decreases with passive and even
decreases even much more
with active surveillance that is linked
to inaction and so that is one of the
things that we want to talk about today
in the context of some of the projects
that have been discussed
in the context of this bioinformatics
for infectious disease
training program so in the program we
decided
to focus our attention on infectious
diseases
and those are primarily categorized
by diseases that are caused by
pathogenic microorganisms so because
we're focused on infectious diseases
caused by these microorganisms we
started talking about
specific examples that are very relevant
to
these diseases around the countries
where we are
working on this training program so for
example uh bacterial diseases
viruses and parasites all cause
very different types of manifestation of
disease
and even though they all trigger the
immune response
we have to contextualize our
understanding and the data
and so we've had to learn a lot about
the life cycle of the malaria
parasite and how the specific stages of
the
disease progression in malaria for
example plays a role
on a variety of interventions and so
having come from a bioinformatics
perspective to
this problem we can really see how there
is so much data available
on various pathogens that cause human
disease
that we can essentially learn through
data
to understand the interaction between
the host
pathogen and the vector to understand
how
the bioinformatic analysis could lead to
impactful
insights and so after we've kind of
reviewed the background of these
different diseases
we've come up with a number of research
examples
that can demonstrate how we can apply
data analysis to address the specific
topic so
here i want to talk about a few examples
and kind of demonstrate some of those uh
in a few minutes using some practical
tools
um so i don't know mohit if you're here
if you could paste the link
to the omixlogic uh
and and we can see some of the examples
of
what these projects really look like
so um on the omixlogic platform
and i think this is something that we
are not okay thank you mohit
we're not going to be able to go through
completely in today's session but it's
important
to understand how these specific
diseases
are manifested as a result of particular
pathogens
and then what kinds of questions could
be asked about these pathogens
so that we can apply bioinformatics
analysis methods
in our analysis to gain some
insights right so for example what we
covered so far was
how we can categorize protein function
and how
genomic data variation could be a way to
look into
various immune pressures that are
affecting the genomic variation
of covet 19. and so describing these
these issues we can really start to
focus in on particular topics of
interest
for example on how we can study the
replication and colonization
of pathogens how we can study the
impact of that colonization that leads
to cell death
or organ function and interference
and so to talk specifically about some
of these examples
i want to first of all talk about what
is this
genomic data and how does it help us
understand
these pathogens so first of all the
importance of genomic data in infectious
diseases
cannot be underestimated we are really
looking
at an unprecedented look at the
diversity and the variability of
pathogens
throughout their development cycle and
the cause of disease at a single person
individual as well as the whole
community
or a a country a region
or the whole world right so we are
looking at unprecedented
amount of detail and so when you think
about that
detail we can look at the viral
evolution how the pathogen spreads
and causes disease as it adapts to a
population
we can look at the interaction between
that pathogen
and other maybe less harmful pathogens
that are competing for resources
and domination right and we can also
look
at the host response and so all of these
areas of
research have been uh profoundly
affected
by the emergence availability and the
lower
costs of genomic data so here's an
overview
of how in the last 20 years this
availability of genomic data has led
to an increasing understanding of how
cells function at the molecular level
and allowed us to understand
the major causes of some of these
diseases in terms of their specific
mechanism of interaction and so one of
the things that we have to do to
really utilize this data to gain those
insights
is we have to turn to the methods of
analysis
because ultimately just raw data cannot
be used in any way
to actually make any kind of conclusions
about
the pathogen itself so right now i want
to give you
uh an example of a particular project
that we will
just briefly take a look at using the
tbion for platform so if you could go
with me
to server server.tbioinfo
and i want to demonstrate one of the
pipelines that will combine
several different analysis methods so
that we can
start looking at the output from this
pipeline and think how do we interpret
the results of this analysis
so thank you mohit for posting the link
beeps if we have
the demo accounts here as well for those
of you that do not have them
please let me know if you're on this
link already
by putting in number one in the chat box
so i'll know that you're here
on the platform
okay thank you everyone
and uh
and if beep say you could share the
demo details for those that don't have
access
yeah is in another meeting so let me
find it and share it in a while
okay thank you so what we'll do here
is we will take a look at one of the
demo pipelines that helps us understand
the translation of genomic data into a
particular insight
so please go with me right here
yes parissa we are mohit is just getting
those details for you right now but i
will just start the demonstration and
then mohit will
share the details in a second so i will
go right here to this section under
virology
again if you think about
contextualization
the methods as well as data have to be
contextualized so that they are
easy to use to ask specific questions
and so this whole section
about virology has been developed to
assist with that process
all right thank you mohit he has shared
those details
so i'll just give it another couple of
minutes if you have logged in with the
demo account or if you have your
personal account
information please log in with your
personal account
if you don't have an account please log
in with the demo account and then i will
continue
to speak about this section and show you
a couple of examples so if you have
logged in
put number two in the chat box
all right thank you leanna
murray
okay let's give it a minute until
everybody else is in okay thank you
parissa
all right great excellent thank you
everyone
so we'll go right here to this section
virus quasi species
and i will open this drop down right
here
so you can see in this drop down that
there are several different
demos and essentially these are data
sets that have been already analyzed and
we'll just take a look at
what are the methods to arrive at that
analysis result and then we'll see how
to visualize that
analysis result to interpret it and
think about
what might be the value of that research
question
so we'll look at this first demo
virus msa and phylogeny
and when you click on that you see this
interface that essentially combines
together several different methods of
analysis that could be
relevant to various types of input
data from genomic sequencing so
one of the issues with genomic
sequencing is
quality control and quality control
is for next generation sequencing
essentially comes down to the quality of
the actual sequence reads
including different technical adapters
that should be eliminated and so you can
see those
data pre-processing steps right here
then we have some options for mapping
so mapping onto the reference genome we
have raw sequencing reads
you with those raw sequencing reads you
can do a number of downstream
analyses including variant calling
the mutability or how frequently we
observe mutations
at the consensus and the primarily
subconsensus
level differential variant calling when
we want to compare
groups of samples and then we also want
to
sometimes estimate time course dynamics
of
mutations so then we have a specific
section here related to not point
mutations but
whole deletions of viral genomes this is
specifically for viruses
and then here we have a number of
additional
multiple sequence alignments and
haplotype detection
for inference of phylogenetic
relationships
as well as the coding mutations that
could impact protein protein
interactions and so all of that is right
here
the way that this section is organized
is you can click on start
and we will take one example to just
kind of think about the implications
of a particular question so this example
is taken from a paper about
the emergence of source code 2 and as
you know
up until today this question remains
what is the actual origin of source code
2 and how can we infer
the dynamics of the spread of
a pathogen like source code 2 to go back
and trace it to a potential original
host
and so we'll take this data set and you
can click on ok
to go to the next step and then you will
have a number of
uh one actual step highlighted as the
next possible step so now we'll do
multiple sequence alignment so we've
loaded some data this data
has to do with source code too we want
to perform multiple sequence alignment
and essentially
find the specific variants that could be
interesting for the next question that
we want to ask
now at the genomic level these mutations
oftentimes do not translate to
a change in the amino acids so they're
non
so they are silent mutations we don't
observe any change
and then we want to identify how
some of those mutations actually do have
a
an impact on amino acid sequences and so
here we have
a specific example of different amino
acids that have different
chemical properties and so now we can
click on
okay select codon position because
viral mutations only occur
more frequently in specific codons for
example
here you can see some of the examples of
which positions
cause a change in different codons
and then we want to use all of the
phylogenetic methods to infer the
relationships between
sequences by reconstructing a
phylogenetic tree
or thinking about how did these viruses
emerge from some common ancestors
and so how is the observed variation
in the data that we have a
representation of some kind of
a evolutionary relationship and so you
can see an example here
of how we can reconstruct this
phylogenetic tree now since we're going
to be using
multiple methods of relationship uh
using phylogenetic tree reconstruction
we want to then analyze these different
trees to think about
how we can think of the real kind of
molecular
dynamics that happen in the evolution
as opposed to just looking at results of
a particular method right so
if we are just following one methodology
we are
oftentimes biased by that methodology
being developed to answer specific
questions
and here we want to analyze all of the
various
results to identify a common trend
and that common trend is more likely to
be representative
of the actual biology that we're going
to be looking at so there's a method
called tree space
essentially we'll analyze the different
trees and help us decide
what are some of the most representative
trees of what's actually don't want
i'll click on ok right here now to
finish this pipeline i'm going to click
on
end and i will see this result for
download pipeline output files and so
we're not going to necessarily
look at all of these files but we're
going to take a look at
one of the example files that will help
us think about
the translation of the insights from
this analysis
from a very specific data set that we
have collected
to ask downstream question what is the
impact
of the identified mutations and how can
we use our understanding of the
relationship between different viral
sequences
to ask the question where could they
have originated
so here you have different types of
outputs
like phylogenetic analysis so here you
can see the
multiple sequence in fasta and clustal
you can see a visual representation of
the
tree the phylogenetic tree using
multiple different methods
of reconstructing that phylogenetic tree
and you also will see how that tree will
be done separately for group
one and group two because the input
files that we had
are organized into groups but one of the
important files that is right here
is called full table tsv so let's take a
look at this table
so you can download it's a fairly large
file but you can click on it and we'll
start downloading
and we'll take a look at what all the
information
from this analysis could be available
for now asking specific questions right
so i'll
take a look at this and i'll open it in
excel just so that we can visually see
what's inside this data and please let
me know
all of those that are following along
and doing these steps
if you can actually download and
open this file in your on your computer
to just kind of see what's in there
okay maybe you can put number three in
the chat box if you were able to make
this pipeline
and get the same results
all right thank you anonymous anonymous
has anyone else gotten this file
okay i'll just give it one moment all
right thank you nigel
so again you can see uh some of this
uh some of the steps that we took if you
just scroll down right here
we went from loading some genomic data
performing multiple sequence alignment
and mapping nucleotides to amino acid
codons
and then we performed a number of
phylogenetic analyses
to create a representative phylogenetic
tree
and so now we want to look at this one
file that kind of combines this
information together
to start asking the questions of how do
we
analyze what's in the analysis results
to get some actionable insights so how
many of you have this file
on your computer and can see what's
inside
all right thank you maureen so again if
you are just joining
we are repeating this pipeline just to
kind of see what are some inputs and
outputs and think about
what is the translational value of such
a data set
okay thank you sarah
okay let me explain what is
in this particular data here you have
the position on the reference genome
that is
followed by five different columns
that indicate first of all this
is the sequence of nucleotides here
the sequence on the positive and the
negative strand of amino acids
then you have some alternatives for the
positive and the
negative strand now typically this kind
of an output would be useful for
dna reference genomes right then you
would have to do
um okay then you would have to
go through both positive and negative
strains but in our case it's just an rna
virus
and here you can see an example of
how the this particular sequence
is different from this sequence
in the reference genome so here we have
for example a mutation right
there's a t instead of an a right if the
reference genome contains a certain
sequence we can see here
the genomic variation that is observed
in different sequences here we see a lot
of deletions
right so as we look through this data we
can now scroll down a little bit and
we'll get you
a translated portion and this translated
portion
includes the translation of codons so
these are trinucleotide codons
into a particular amino acid
right so now after we go through this
we can actually see that the picture is
becoming
more and more complex we have
the reference in nucleotide and amino
acid
we have multiple sequences
and for all of these sequences we have
thousands of positions so 30 over 30
000 positions right so the question is
with the availability of all of this
data
what are some of the questions that are
coming to mind
in the context of this project so if
anyone has
any specific ideas what might be the
questions that we can ask about this
particular
analysis result
and then just by seeing what's on the
screen
or seeing this on your computer you see
all of this data right we have
30 000 positions through this reference
genome
we have a bunch of samples that we can
look up
for example we have these uh different
ids that we can probably look up on
ncbi how do we interpret this kind of an
analysis
what is the value of this analysis and
how do we quickly get
from where we were with the raw input
files to some kind of an insight
okay so anonymous is saying which
positions may hold
similarities with other known sequences
so where
are regions that are similar right
so that is one of the questions marie is
saying
the similarity between reference genome
and the other genomes
or mutations okay so how can we now
quickly find those regions
of similarity or dissimilarity between
these genomic sequences
great now if i just ask you the question
how do i find mutations here it would
probably take a while right i would have
to do
some more analysis of this
data which is already the result of the
analysis
but i have to do many downstream steps
to actually get an idea of
where the more or the less variable
sections of this genome
what are the sequences that are grouped
together by similarity or by difference
and how do i interpret the mutations
that do have an impact
on a particular region of a a protein
that i'm interested in
and which ones are not right so
initially this analysis
is hypothesis generating i am starting
to get ideas about
what i could do with this information
and now i have to do some
plan some downstream steps of analysis
to start getting
answers to those questions so now let me
show you how this particular
data set could be used to understand
similarity between sequences right
instead of looking at particular
regions per nucleotide or per amino acid
i can actually look at this phylogenetic
tree
and in this phylogenetic tree i can
start
gaining some insights about what am i
looking for in the specifics of
those sequence similarities so here i
have a number of groups
group one group two group three
and group four right and so i can see
what that
these groups for example group four
seems to be the most distant from all of
the other groups
groups one and two though seem to be
fairly close together
right and so based on this understanding
i can formulate the next question well
what
makes these groups close together right
why are they
closer together and if they are close
but not the same group
what are still the differences between
them so i've refined my question
from a general question to a more
specific one
and i'm starting to ask the question
where specifically
are they different okay
yes this works for any kinds of genomes
the time to analyze the genomes would
take a while but you would still get the
results
so the same file that we looked at in
excel
could actually be visualized in a more
informative
way let's take a look at this specific
example
using our sequence navigator
so please go with me to this link
and you will see the exact same data set
that we're dealing with
but in a visual format okay so when you
get to this
link you want to go to data
and select right here comparison birth
death coronavirus
okay so please let me know once you're
on this page and you see what i
see in the sequence navigator
maybe put a number or yes in the chat
box so i know that you're following
along
all right thank you swati
all right excellent so again we see here
the exact same information that we see
in excel
but instead of just looking at thousands
of rows
we see this information in a very
condensed way
and so based on what you see in this
visual representation of that data
could you tell me where is group one
and group two so again i will open up
this phylogenetic tree
okay and let's take a look at the names
of sequences
okay so here you see names of sequences
are right here
and here you see similar names of
sequences so from looking at this
phylogenetic tree
where i see group one and group two are
closer together
what are those groups you can hover over
different elements
on the screen and let me know what are
these two groups
okay does anyone have any idea if i go
over to the screen
right and again i can hover over here
for example they're
already organized into groups what what
do i see
okay so somebody said protein s so right
here we have different
okay so two groups right we have group
one and two
we know that they are closer together
what are those two groups
lyanna is saying sars okay so
here indeed i have the reference is sars
but what are the two groups that you see
closest together
again let me show you the phylogenetic
tree
a ay613947
so you can see that all of these ays six
one three nine four seven what is this
this is sars right and then what is
group number two
so this is sorry this was group number
two group number one let's take this one
lc five to two nine seven
five lcc
uh two two nine nine seven
five right here right all right great so
uh thank you uh vladimir vadivel
and liana right so uh we have here sars
and covid so sars1 and sars2
covet 19 and sars1 seem to be the
closest ones
and so we have here mers we have
here beta coronaviruses and then we have
covet 19 and stars one now beta corona
viruses are coronaviruses that cause the
common cold
mers was the middle eastern respiratory
uh sorry respiratory source
and that was a specific outbreak
related to the middle east and in
i believe the far east so here we have
two groups that seem to be closer
together now if we look at these two
groups visually
instead of in the full sequence of what
we were looking at before
where are the specific differences
between those two groups right so again
these are the two groups the pink and
the red
they're the closest to each other how do
we know
in which regions we observe the most
variation
okay so now we're looking instead of
this
bar right here we're looking at this bar
right here right so here you have the
reference
but in terms of the protein sequences
so these include the orf1ab polyprotein
the surface glycoprotein or the s
protein
or 3a envelope protein membrane
or 6 or 7a or 8
nucleocapsid and orf10
so in which protein do we observe the
most variation
between group one and group two
does anyone have any idea about what
could be
that region now let me explain some of
these colorings
as you can see each one of these
represents a bin
these bin size are 500 nucleotide long
and the more variation is observed from
the reference
the more red you see the color of this
bin so for example if you look at this
bin
the number of variations from the
reference is 436 out of 500 right so
that's almost 100
if you look at the gray one the
variation is zero so there are zero
mutations
in this specific bin so if you look
through these colors
where are the colors with the most
variation from the reference
between these two groups
okay so just type in the name of the
protein that has the most
variation
any ideas
okay so for the okay or if 1ab
so here we have orf1ab
okay io is saying around 23 000. so
around 23
000 that could be right here now what
what is this protein
uh okay how do you get the protein
sequence so here you have the proteins
right
this is the reference genome it's got
the different proteins you can click on
it
and see what is this protein so for this
for example is
the spike like a protein here you have
the orf 1ab so just one
okay all right great great thank you all
right we're getting some answers so orf
1ab
or surface black approach so let's take
a look so indeed
in orf1av we're observing these
particular changes right 213
fairly cons consistently 180 207
and then here in the surface we have
252.
so if we are thinking about the total
number of mutations in a particular
region
because this region is so large
we do expect to find a lot more changes
however if we're looking at a particular
position
that has a lot more variation in a
very focused region we are talking about
the spike glycoprotein now to understand
again contextualizing our analysis with
knowledge about
how this works we know that the spike
glycoprotein
is responsible for cell entry and
therefore infection of the cell
and so if we think about the
relationship between
these different pathogenic viruses and
their ability to cause disease
maybe one of the interesting areas for
us to look at
would be the spike glycoprotein it's
also important because
in the context of prevention of the
entry
of that glyphoprotein into the cell we
do need to look at the variation in the
spike glycoprotein
so to understand the impact of this
uh of this uh variation specifically in
this position
we actually don't know anything else
based on sequence alone we now need to
take from
sequence into this structure and we need
to understand
how does this specific variation
can affect the structural properties of
this protein
so let's go on and let's look at how
this actually could help us understand
those
differences now i clicked on protein
compare and this is our
ability to now ask a downstream question
when we think of a specific area
a region on the sequence that has an
impact
on the structure how can we find within
that structure
a particular region that has an impact
on the interaction between two proteins
so here i can load the whole structure
or i can actually
choose the different proteins and i can
also choose the different ways i
represent this protein but i've loaded
here the whole structure
of the surface glycoprotein and i'm
looking at the surface render of that
structure now this is a comparison
between different hosts bats
and humans and i can see here a specific
non-random pattern that emerges right
and so
in this example i can see that this
pattern is actually represented by
high variability in red low variability
or higher consensus higher
conservation with gray and higher
variability
with red so if i look at this
sequence i can see that there is a
binding region
in this particular red color that is
affected
and also some specific positions inside
this protein now this allows me
as you have seen to quickly go from
sequence relationship between sequences
to the impact on the structure and
ultimately to start thinking about
the impact of the variance that i
observe
on the genomic sequence to the
protein protein interaction now the
question is
can i apply this kind of a visual
exploration tool to a number of other
problems
that i might be thinking about let me
give you
an example so we went from
the platform where we have access to a
number of tools
that instead of looking at various types
of scripts
and solutions that solve a focus problem
combine different scripts into a rapid
workflow
that you can execute to prepare data
for interactive exploration this is
important because
we have such an abundance of genomic
data
that is highly variable and that allows
us to ask
questions about practically anything
right and inside those available
sequences
of genomic data we need to understand
here is an example of
variance of concern here we have
an example of uh the types of
sequences that we can find right so this
is ncbi virus
where we can literally find information
about
any type of virus that has been
sequenced
we have a lot of variability
with collected data that we already
discussed that can cause
bias and nevertheless we tend to think
about that variability
to kind of detect these major trends
right so what is being reported today
a lot of it in the media is how
the general variability between
sequences or particular variants of
concern
emerge in different places around the
world now if i think about
how i would want to textualize this type
of data
analysis with the available data that i
have i would want to focus it and
develop
a custom solution that that allows me to
ask
much more focused questions on the based
on the available data
and based on performed analysis
and so that brings me to the next
important question genomic data
represents huge data sets with
variable properties and those variable
properties are based on
the type of data that was collected and
by whom when
and where and how it is stored and how
it was
uh annotated with important metadata
that allows me to
ask specific questions with a level
of reproducibility and reliability and
so that is why
when we put together these analysis
pipelines
we're essentially trying to make them
logical and we're trying to make sure
that the data
that we put into the pipelines come
with suggestions for analysis so here
you can see
as we've seen before this guided process
this guided process allows us to
put in the data and allow the platform
suggest some kind of an analysis
that essentially leads to color coding
that is logical
explanation of methods so that as i
analyze the data i can learn about the
specific methods that i'm using
providing different types of inputs and
outputs that i can
visually explore and ask downstream
questions
and essentially leads to a guided and
reproducible
workflow that i could then apply
to specific data sets that i have
designed around a specific question
and so this is consistent across these
many different
areas that we have already seen now
when we go from doing such analysis to
an
actual insight that is actionable we
want to design
a context so here historically you can
see
the context of different types of
interventions
such as vaccines anti-bacterial
drugs so antibiotics you can see
different preventive measures that have
been effective in reducing
the prevalence and you can see different
types of
pathogens that have caused disease over
time now
given the variability of approaches that
have developed over time
we live at a time when genomic data
availability
is making it possible to start asking
very specific questions
but instead of looking at general trends
like this we need to design
very specific questions around specific
geographic regions
about specific pathogens about specific
data sets that we have access to to
start formulating
very specific data sets with analysis
methods
that will provide us with actionable
results and so when we look at this
tool that essentially was designed to
contextualize
data we are looking at an example of
streamlining this approach right making
it faster translating the raw data
to actionable insights in a much faster
way
and so what we are proposing to do
with this tool and we're inviting all of
you to participate in this effort
is to start designing specific questions
around specific pathogens geographic
regions
and challenges like vaccine design drug
design
or understanding of the basic mechanism
of disease
that could be answered with this tool so
i'll just give you one more example
and then i will pass it on to mohit to
talk about how
you can also start generating project
ideas and research questions
that could lead to some of these
important insights
actionable insights that could lead to
the improvement
this is another variation of the same
tool
you can see the same concept of bins
instead of samples these are passages
that allow us to study the impact of
frequency of mutations
on variability in the viral
quasi species that tend to be associated
with virulence so the same is known
about many different pathogens if you
think about the immune system that
actually makes a lot of sense
if you have one type of an enemy
that consistently attacks in the same
way you can easily identify
and neutralize that enemy but if your
enemies are very
and they attack in very different ways
and you have to adapt to each one
to address the challenges that they pose
that spreads out the immune system thin
and therefore the infection overall in
one place
will be able to breach the defenses and
so
here you can see an example of
poliovirus
rate of mutation variability based on
specific positions
in the reference genome and the
associated
proteins that are being produced from
these polyprotein sequences
that allow us to quickly navigate this
complex data set
and start asking the question about what
types of mutations we are
seeing and how we can see
the specific uh variations uh
i'll just turn this on right here that
could be
detrimental or beneficial to
viral replication right so for example
here i can see a region with
detrimental variation so i can start
asking the question
how does this specifically affect
viral structure right and so a lot of
the connections that i'm trying to make
are going to be very obvious
if i use this multi-layered integration
tool to essentially combine
the different types of data that i have
into
a single exploration environment where i
can rapidly go from
raw sequencing data to very specific
types of
insights that i could then leverage to
understand the mechanism of disease and
to translate my understanding of this
disease
happening to an intervention or a
prevention strategy
so as i mentioned these types of
questions
are being asked by participants of our
omics logic training programs and one of
these programs
is focused on malaria and covet 19.
so in this program we are going through
different types of genomic data
different methods of analysis and
ultimately designing
questions that will help ask
the specific data sets specific
types of questions that are important to
understand those pathogens
so to talk about that more i'm going to
invite
dr mohit mazunder to take over and give
you some examples of student
projects that they are working on but
before
he takes over i want to ask if you have
any questions so i can answer those
right now
okay so i'll be here and you can
continue posting your questions in the
chat box
i will paste it on i will pass it on to
mohit to talk about those projects thank
you
thank you india let me share mystery
okay hello everyone i'm mohit majumdar
and as a co-mentor and project guide
every day i have been able to work on
exciting and this dynamic field of
bioinformatics and data science and so
far been able to publish 30
bioinformatics projects in some of the
peer reviewed journals
and currently our team has been working
on more important bioinformatics
projects
in collaboration with several research
labs that are practicing translational
sciences
so to talk more about the research
fellowship
i just wanted to show you a slide here
so about the research fellowship or the
independent project
the journey to completing an independent
research project is
really complex right you first
learn about a particular topic
and then you review data sets or
databases for specific project
you know data sets and then acquire the
skills to
analyze that data sets right so in the
even in the established educational
system where this is going on as a part
of their phd program or a master's
program all around the world
this process can take like years and it
it is like
dependent on several factors and some of
those factors are like having the right
faculty resources
and the mentors that can guide this
process
so
there are questions i guess so what i
wanted to tell you is that
uh this omixlogic research fellowship is
really a cool opportunity
for many students and graduates to be
able to develop
and complete an independent project so
this
research fellowship program is
structured is a structured program
that allows participants to work on a
to work on self-paced and a flexible
schedule
and work with a team of experts on
cutting-edge topics in uh healthcare
research
so some of the examples here as you can
see
uh the participants started learning
from the workflows
that allows them to learn about complex
bioinformatics pipeline
and algorithms and their outputs
i don't think your slides are showing
the way you intend them to
um okay yeah it was oh i think
i have to then log out and come back but
i just wanted to tell you i mean tell
everyone uh
about the uh about the research
fellowship program
and one of the major advantage of this
program is to
you know you you'll be able to
communicate the outcome of this research
and get feedback from experts
and get feedback uh from experts and
peers to improve the project
by including information from literature
and the analytical steps
so most of our past participants have
gone through this entire process
of starting from the training and next
to work on example data sets
and then exploring the publicly
available datasets
to come up with you know uh research
questions and then work on this research
questions and then complete
it into a poster conference presentation
so here you can see a
poster on rna sequencing uh and use
user use of rna sequencing in lung
cancer in lung cancer
so similarly we have been working on
several research areas as early pointed
out so we are working on
infectious diseases we are working on
cancer genomics and
agriculture so it depends on the
research question being asked by you
so we trying we as a team are trying to
uh help guide this entire process
because
this is like an opportunity that you can
work on
as as a part of your uh you know thesis
as a part of your own interest to
develop something
uh off of of your own interest
so these materials and these uh entire
process is
being reviewed and it's quite uh it has
been quite effective and
transformational
and to talk more about like the upcoming
opportunities
and what we will be doing next i would
like to invite
uh miss bifsha so
uh over to you peepshop thank you
everyone and if you have any questions
regarding the research fellowship
program please feel free to reach out to
us so
i'll be putting my email address and if
you have already
a research question in your mind that
you wanted to discuss to learn about the
possibilities of doing that
whether we can be able to you know work
with the data which is
which is publicly available please feel
free to reach out
to me as well so i'll be putting my
email address in the chat
and thank you everyone
thank you so much uh dr mohit so i will
go ahead and
walk everybody through this entire
process i know that everybody has a
question how can i join a program how
can i get started
so let us look at everything uh one by
one
so that we are able uh to go ahead
and start with it so the first platform
that i welcome
everybody to get started with this
platform the registration to this
platform is free
so what you do to register on the learn
automix logic platform it's a learning
tool
or an educational portal so you go to
login
right here if you already have an
account you can sign up or sign in with
the same email id i already have an
email id and account with my email or
you can also log in via any of these
social links
so please feel free to create an account
along with me right now
so that i can introduce you to some of
these courses and resources
so if you come in here there you would
come across some of these
courses and we have designed them in a
step-wise manner but not necessarily
that everybody has to
start right with the first course and
these courses have lessons which
are a mix of uh
open or free lessons while some of them
are lessons that you have to subscribe
to or which are available to as part of
all of our omics logic programs
so is everybody there on learned
omics logic can you put number one in
the chat box so that i know that you're
here
okay i o and lina thank you anybody else
here
at least five people who would be able
to sign up
thank you swati gulam anonymous
anonymous
right so we have five people have
already registered and
please note that these courses which are
not marked with a star
are completely open completely free for
anybody who is coming in and wants to
get started today and right away
so great that everybody is starting with
the courses similarly you will have a
course on
introduction to bioinformatics
then there are several other courses
now today's session we discussed a
little bit about genomics
so if you come down along to the
genomics lesson
you would start learning from dna
structure and variance then working
towards
uh getting introduced to how to work
with dna sequences in r then getting an
introductory overview of what genomics
is all about
and then you progress to these lessons
so here you would find that we have
provided you
courses which you can access like this
by signing up for free and get started
right away right today
so please feel free to explore anything
any of the topic that you have an
interest in and if you have any feedback
for us
please reach out to us at marketing at
pine dot bio
and share those feedback with us
yes so ramabhat if you have interest in
genomics please go ahead and take the
genomics course we welcome
everybody to go ahead and check these
courses
and we also have a few projects here
as well and we keep on adding more
projects here
so these projects are taken from
peer-reviewed publications
and what they help you exactly is by
learning
this entire project process so you are
able to see
uh from these projects like for example
if i'm to look into the ebola virus
project
you can see like what is the
introduction
to this entire ebola virus story right
here what are the bioinformatics methods
utilized
and in conclusion and you would have to
do some kind of hands-on
to learn more about how this project
have been executed that gives you a
better idea
if you're planning to work on a project
of your own
so these are some example data sets or
example projects that are available
and of course the data sets are also
provided along with them
and we also have a full set of courses
on
r and python now the rn python courses
have code blocks within them which means
that
you do not need to install our python in
your computer
ramawhat has a question how should i
register for the course map
so as i showed you you have to login
to learn.comics logic and once you log
in you will have
access to the courses now i will talk
about
that you are seeing that there are few
lessons which have a star
sign marked as a premium lesson so how
do you get
access to that those lessons
are the full set of courses available on
this platform
comes as part of our omics logic
programs
some of which we talked about today like
the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases the genomic program which is
ongoing right now
and the upcoming transcriptomics program
so i wanted
to actually take you through the
upcoming programs that we have
and talk a little more about
each of the programs right here so
let us take a look at these upcoming
programs
so we keep on updating this page
so anytime you want to join or check
which programs are there you can go
ahead and check this
so the first program is a bi-informatics
research fellowship this
is the research project
program and this program is
available all around the year and what
we usually
do in this program is a research fellow
joins for either a three months
or a six months period and
these are the typical timelines that we
have and we provide for you to go ahead
and develop your own project as dr mohit
was speaking about earlier so
in the three months program is
recommended to anyone
who has an idea of developing a project
but is
not sure how to get started
so for the six months program we
recommend it to anybody else who wants
to work on a longer term in the project
in the means of that they want to
take the project forward to a poster or
a publication
though that depends of course on the
complexity of your project
on the time that you are available to
give for that project but we typically
have
seen that our participants are able to
come up with a project even
high school students in very short
period of time which is like three
months
and for this program we typically
recommend
at least six to eight hours per week
to be able to come up with that project
so the program
starts with training and then we work
with you
by assigning you a mentor from our team
who works along with you in helping you
develop that project so you go through
an
intense training session and this
project
please note that is your own project we
do not offer you the topics or we do not
provide the topics
you are free to choose your own topic
what we do is provide you that
mentorship where you are able to
understand whether the project that you
have chosen
is going to have some reproducible
results
whether that project you can apply it in
different
places like for publication or if you
want to submit a paper for review
poster presentation so we work with you
uh through this and here are some of
these
examples right here of projects
so i'm also going to be sharing this
link in the chat box
for everybody
and you would see that these projects
are done
by a mixed group of people by mixed i
mean that
participants have come from high school
from research level
from undergraduate masters phd level so
this is really like for everybody
whoever is
interested in doing a project you can
actually go ahead and watch
these video sessions which are recorded
by the participants themselves where
they speak about their own project so
that you can learn about this entire
process
so i would leave you all to explore this
now the next program that we offer
and which is coming up right now after
this is
this program in collaboration with all
india institute of medical
sciences new delhi so we have this
workshop on lymphoma
and you can register for this program
by filling out the form at the bottom of
the page which i'm going to be coming to
next
then the other program which we
discussed briefly in today's session is
the omixlogic transcriptomics program so
this is also
part of the bioinformatics for
infectious disease program
that we have been discussing today so
this program is starting now on
april 16th and the registrations are
open to join this program right at the
moment
so you can go ahead and check this
program as well as you understand that
this program will have
transcriptomics for infectious disease
research and we also have
another program that is starting in
india with a lot of our collaborators
and this is on biomedical data science
and drug discovery so you can also join
this program
and so how do you join either of these
programs you have to fill only one form
and once you come down here you can
choose which
program you are interested in so you do
not have to fill multiple forms you can
choose
right here and even if you want to apply
for multiple programs uh consider
filling out the form twice
so that you are able to submit it twice
and you will receive
details regarding this in case any of
the details
are not very clear to you again
or you want to ask us more questions
please feel free to again reach out to
me marketing at pine.bio and i would be
able to clear those
out for you so abu curry has a question
here
i would like to address it at this
moment are the python coding
courses paid so the python coding
courses again some lessons are free
while some lessons
require a subscription so
if you can get the recording of the
session so i think daniel
uh yes we will be sharing the recording
of the session of course
so yeah so i think that i have answered
the question
now on regarding access to the tbio info
platform
so the programs that we have mentioned
here
all come with educational access to tbio
info which means that
whatever cost that you're paying for
each of these program covers the cost of
the tbio info license
but in case you are interested in just
exploring the tbio info
platform we also have
uh another licensing here which
makes it clear for you how to get
started
with getting access to the tbi info
platform it's called the gene lab
for researchers we offer a research
license where you're able to work with
your own data
at 99 per month but for first-time users
you have to
take this license for three months which
is 297.
so that is the research license while
the educational license which comes with
all of our programs costs 75 dollars per
month
while all of the programs already
include this in their pricing
so anybody who joins any of the
omixlogic training programs will have
access to tbio info the access would be
created by
us and sent to you so if you have any
questions regarding that as well
uh we would be able to help you with
this so
let us know if you have any questions
about this and i will be able to help
you
and while you are here i wanted to
welcome you to join us here
on linkedin and some of our other social
media networks so we have this group
in linkedin where we keep on sharing
many interesting posts
and not just posts we also keep sharing
job opportunities as well as
any other things which are relevant to
the bioinformatics community that we
have so please feel free
to go ahead and join this group we also
have a group
in facebook so please feel free to
follow us on facebook
as well and here is our instagram page
so we also keep on sharing all of these
updates
on instagram as well as do polls
sometimes on our story so
please go ahead and follow us there if
you are
more active on instagram and now again i
would like to go ahead and ask if you
have
any questions so that i may answer them
and
we can then take those questions so
thank you all again
and while we are going towards the end
what i wanted to mention here is that we
also
offer scholarships for our programs
that any participant can avail these
scholarships
are given to participants
with whom we have an interaction so the
process of the scholarship is this that
you fill out the form at the bottom of
this page
you need to mention your references from
your college or university
who go ahead and join that meeting with
us so any one of your references can
get on that meeting with us and once we
have spoken
to the reference and understood why you
would need that scholarship
uh you would be receiving all the
details from our end
so you can use utilize this option for
any of our programs that are here so
please feel free to
post them down and fill out that form
if you think that you require that
scholarship to join any of the programs
and i hope that
this was clear to everybody so again if
you have
any questions if you want to reach out
to us we have the email id marketing at
pine.bio
we have also shared dr mohit's email id
so you can also reach out to him
for any kind of research question that
you may have
so thank you all again for joining us
today
yeah thank you so much murray
okay it's wonderful to have you all here
we'll share the recording and all of the
links
to today's session via email with you
all
and have a lovely week ahead everybody
thank you again